mes camarades l'appelait le vidangeur
des décorateurs artiste aux mille
talents claude jasmin a été à la fois
journaliste écrivain scénariste
marionnettiste animateurs et peintre
quand on me dit que je suis écrivain ça
me laisse un petit peu trop songeur né
dans le quartier villeray à montréal en
claude jasmin a fait ses débuts au
théâtre avant de se mettre à l'écriture
en plus de 60 ans il a écrit près de 50
livres lui écrivait de cezus ses
souvenirs il écrivait son enfance et son
adolescence son roman la petite patrie
qui a inspiré la série télévisée du même
nom est passé à l'histoire
ainsi l'interprète se souvient une ayant
pas non plus la vocation pour devenir
prêtre avocat ou médecin avait beaucoup
de complicité avec tous très très gai
très boute en train
comme je dis ça y est t'es tu accueilles
aimait beaucoup la la controverse
j'avais pas que les parents me disent
pas ce que c'est que ce garçon est un
conteur infatigable claude jasmin n'a
jamais cessé d'écrire récoltant au
passage de nombreux prix c'est pas pour
rien qui s'est mérité autant de
distinctions notamment le prix
athanase-david georges a joué était
capable de dresser le portrait de son
époque
on devrait de nuit prix à ceux qui ont
arrêté d'écrire claude jasmin a toujours
été un libre penseur qui ne craignait
pas la polémique
c'est a mis en garde de précieux
souvenirs très grand monsieur un être
spectaculaire dans tous les sens du
terme un sondage scientifique plupart de
mes beaux-frères décédé à l'âge de 90
ans
claude jasmin fait partie de ces
romanciers qui ont marqué le québec
moderne
ici louis philippe ouimet radio-canada
maurienne